الى النتيجه
وتحصى ما زالت
سليمان فرنجيه 51 جهاد الزعور تسعه وخمسين
زياد بارود سته لبنان الجديد ثمانيه ورقه
بيضاء
واحد
ورقه مرات واحد
127 يطلعوا 127 دوله الرئيس في ورقه ناقصه
منيح اللي فيه ممثلين عن الكلمه موجودين
هون
رجعوا عد
ل
مع انه ما كنت راضي زياد بارود يمكن سبعه
عيد التصويت دوله الرئيس
ترتين بتفرق عن 59 دوله الرئيس
زياد بارود 7
هيدي بس لحتى نكون ممثلين يكون عم بيقروا
زياد بارود سبعه
سبعه بس نحن علينا سته عدينا سته
ما بتاثر
لشفافيه الجميع لازم نرجع
لانه في خطا هذا الخطا منه عادي ويفضل
يكون يعيد التصويت عن جديد
خلينا نعدل
نرجع نعيد الاوراق ماشي جعد الفرز
خلينا دوله الرئيس في 128 عيد
راح نرجع نعيد يلا
نعيد الفرز عيد الفرج نعيد الفرز بالاول
شو
اوراق الاقتراع موجوده عيد عيدوا الفرز
تعمله معروف
دوله الرئيس نعيد عبد الاصوات ونعيد